I was at the Benjamin Franklin museum in Philly. That dude was not active. He,
although he lived to be like 84 and he was not active and he was
in so much pain for the later part of his life.
And he had gout because he never moved around.
I'd like to eat cheese or whatever the Jesus. So good, dude.
I can never be vegan because of cheese. There's no way put cheese in my casket.
When I die. I love cheese. Don't really put it in my casket with smell bad.
Not that I would be smelling it, but just in case you could smell when you die.
Don't put cheese on the casket. Um, but Benjamin Franklin was,
he invented so many things. It was insane. How,
remember it's remember when like inventor was a job that, I mean,
I know it's still kinda is you can still invent stuff like Elon Musk,
but he's like the only event, like inventor where it was like, oh,
I got to keep coming up. Like in the, in the 17 hundreds, you can be like, yeah,
I got to come up with a new thing.
Cause I'm an inventor because we only got like 17 things so far now everything's
kind of been invented and you gotta like really be really smart to be an
inventor. But back then you could have been a,
you could have been like Michael and [inaudible] had been at an event,
an inventor, like.
Yeah, you know,
this helps when you fall down and you laugh in it it's you don't fart.
You put it in your butt. I was like, oh, you invented the no fart plug.
You can't now get all sorts of butt plugs.
Um,
but did you know Ben Franklin like loved to live it up?
He loved to hookers. Of course he did.
When I heard that I went like this.
Of course he did, dude. Of course,
Ben Franklin loved to get love to Barbara. Of course,
Ben Franklin loved to Berber when he went BRCA cat CAC. Of course he did.
And you know, when he got blow jobs, he would go, you know it.
After the sandwich, I'll get it. You know, I'd love to sit in my chair.
He had a chair for sure. After the sandwich,
I'd love to sit in my chair and just take a relaxing
sit. I'd love to take a sit
and they would be so disrespectful, but it wasn't disrespectful back then. Oh,
excuse me. Could you fetch me a Milky? You know?
And she would come by with a all out and. And he would be like,
I'm going to sit in my chair. And while I finished this,
you know what, I finished this bread sandwich.
Like he would just be this cheese bread sandwich. Would you.
Mind if I just unloaded my sack into your trachea?
And she was like, sure,
because I an event and he'd sit there and then she'd do it.
And then he'd have his eat his sandwich on his belly while he was getting
just sucked off.
And you would be like, oh, oh.
That's how we would bust. And then she'd leave.
And he would like invent a visor. You know,
this keeps you hat your.
Head. Cool. But still the sun out of your eyes.
Now let me take, you know, I would love to get sucked by a Milky.
Let me undress, give me 35 minutes because I'm wearing too many things.
You see what they wore, dude. They, they have guys in Philly,
like in the area where all the museums are.
They have guys still dressed like that, like for fun. And I'm just like, bro,
it's summer. You know, why do you have seven pair of pants on and two boots
and a fake like,
like just an extra pouch and billowy assed pants.
It's 85 degrees. You don't need to do that.
Who are you doing this for the kids that don't really give a.
You can just give them a lollipop and they'd be much happier.
He preferred older women as lovers. Did you know that?
And this is why I have an excerpt from what the it is.
This is unbelievable that he wrote this.
And it was public because if you wrote something like this you're canceled right
now, the faced, he would have just write, Benjamin Franklin didn't give a.
You would just write.
This was a letter he wrote to some people you can just like be like,
when you were in the 1700,
you just write a letter and then just send it to a bunch of people.
And that counted as a book. This is what he says. The face first grows,
Lank and wrinkled. Then the neck, then the breast and arms,
the lower parts, continuing to the last as plump as ever.
So that covering all above with a basket.
And regarding only what is below the girdle,
it is simply impossible of two women to know an ode from a young
one. And as in the dark, all cats are gray.
The pleasure of corporal enjoyment with an old woman is at least equal and
frequently superior. Every neck being by practice,
capable of improvement,
canceled, dude,
this is the part that is the Sid, this respectful dude.
This is the part.
And as in the dark,
all cats are gray.
Doesn't matter. And then this part, so that covering all above,
meaning above the waist with a basket. Yes,
basically.
He's the two live crew of his generation being like,
yeah, put a paper bag over her face if she's and just
empty.
Or sack in her. Hey Ben Franklin.
Did. He's Ben Franklins canceled, bro. I know he discovered electricity.
Anyone invented the bifocals. You know why he invented the,
I don't know why he invented the bifocals.
Didn't matter what rumps we're looking like,
all cats are great when you dim the light.
That's just to go. That's just to show you, dude.
It's a sign of the times and the times are always changing.
And also the leaders are always the most insane people. Donald Trump,
Kanye west, whoever the you want to say, they're they're always the most insane
one. Donald Trump said. Yeah, it was nice Iran. Didn't shoot. Didn't murder.
130 people in cold blood. That was nice to them. Hey, you're crazy.
And that's what that's who the leaders are
in the dark. All cats are gray talking about women. Yeah,
sexist. Hey, put a, oh dude,
let me write a letter to a bunch of people on counter as a book. Hey dude,
just put a bag over her face if she's old and then her.
This guy was a leader.
Wow, dude. He had talk about dad bought that guy, had a granddad bod.
So insane dude. Crazy. How times have changed.